the One Piece manga finally gave us a
glimpse at the absolutely unbelievable
powers of the mysterious rulers of the
world government finally ending all
speculation whether emu and the gorosei
can actually fight they absolutely can
plus we learn a ton of absolutely
mind-blowing information about emu's
true past and confirmation of their
connections with the mysterious Queen
Lily who was introduced in the last
chapter but what might be even more
game-changing is that not one but two
other individuals than Cobra saw the
secret ruler and then barely managed to
escape which means that very very soon
we could see the world government's
darkest secrets revealed to the entire
world and on top of all that it was also
confirmed that vivi's family are
actually part of the legendary d-clan
which means that we could finally be
learning the secrets about the famous
the initial ones Vivi finally reunites
with Luffy on Egghead Island and all of
this could lead Vivi on a Path of
Revenge for her father's death but
overthrowing the world government and
its ruler looks like it just became a
whole lot more difficult because this is
the very first time that we've ever seen
any of the rulers of the world
government use any of their powers and
you cannot even imagine how unbelievably
incredible these abilities seem to be
now everyone is of course asking one
question what exactly are these Powers
well in this chapter we do see emo
transform into some sort of giant
shadowy monster with an enormous mouth
and sharp fangs and he can apparently
even eat fire and might possibly have
the ability to create something like
Shadow arrows but to push this chapter
into even higher levels of insane hype
the five Elders even transform into
giant creatures while they try to
prevent Sabo and the king of alabaster
from leaving the throne room and so with
all of this crazy new information let's
run through some possibilities for what
these Powers may actually B now the
obvious answer here for Emo's abilities
is of course some sort of super powerful
devil fruit that lets the user create
some sort of dark monstrosity however we
already have seen a shadow fruit in the
story and this is definitely different
from those Powers it also cannot be the
darkness fruit since Blackbeard ate that
fruit as well so we're left with a few
options here it could of course be some
sort of legendary devil fruit that
allows emu to either transform into or
create this enormous shadowy creature
and while I'm not totally convinced of
this one another possibility could be a
mythical Moon God fruit as direct
oppositioned to Luffy sunglot fruit and
there's even Japanese mythology to
support this idea since in Japanese the
moon God is called tsukuyomi and is
actually the cast of husband of the sun
god so already there are some
comparisons here but let's take it one
step further because in Japanese
mythology skiomi is set to Strong only
believe in order and will enforce it
whenever he can even going as far as to
kill in order to maintain order
um that sounds pretty much like the
great cleansing that we had heard
mentioned back in chapter 908 but of
course that is just one possibility
another could be that these powers are
from some other previously unknown devil
fruit ability and we're basically just
seeing a silhouette here but that's just
the tip of the iceberg because what has
me super excited about Emo's Powers is
the fact that they could possess a power
that we have never seen before in one
piece and for that let's take this back
to devil fruits and establish a few
things here because first it has been
explained that devil fruit Powers come
from an actual devil inside that fruit
so in a way there does seem to be some
sort of mysterious creature or at least
technological magical energy source
inside second we do know that these
devils are actual things that exist
outside of a particular a fruit because
once a user dies the devil does travel
and is reborn inside another fruit close
by and all of this makes me wonder if
there is an actual devil or many Devils
that don't need to exist inside a fruit
like seriously why do they need some
sort of host in order for their powers
to work they get what I'm saying here if
not let me just lay out Simply for you
what if Emo's real power is to control
or summon actual Devils that can somehow
use their own special abilities just
like devil fruit users and so maybe this
creature that we're seeing in this
chapter might not even be really emu but
is a devil that emu can summon at will
now this is certainly a very wild idea
give you that but one that I think is
possible in my opinion and could allow
emu to use all kinds of crazy Powers you
might be thinking of hold on Ohara Dr
vegapunk told us that devil fruits
represent the desires of someone to have
a certain power but keep in mind that
this is just an in world theory and that
doesn't mean that these Devils can't be
the product of those original desires
and I mean who knows imuente gorose
might even be the original Devils or
have awakened the devil itself inside of
their devil fruits also it would make
complete sense to me that emo has a
power that surpasses all of our
imaginations similar to how basically no
one expected the actual powers of
Luffy's gear 5 transformation so maybe
this is some way to counter devil fruits
and it has been a secret ability all
along that is kind of separate from
devil fruits or opposed to it but
whatever the true answer might be here
there can no longer be any doubt at all
that emo is a real threat and not just
like a random dude who can operate
behind the scenes and the same can of
course now also be said for the gorosei
who have these Wilds beasts looking like
Transformations which we unfortunately
don't get to see outside of their
Silhouettes as well however however
their shapes do hint that they look like
ancient or mythical creatures so
wouldn't be too surprised at all if they
each have mythical Zone devil fruits
themselves no matter what the answer to
this riddle is they are clearly real
monsters in their own right which makes
me extremely excited for when we return
to echat Island and see Sans Saturn join
the battle against Luffy because this
chapter basically confirmed that the
godosei are also not some washed up
scrubs but that they can actually use
some insanely overpowered abilities in
battle as well and speaking of said
battle and echid Island we could be in
for a very big surprise when we reach
the climax of that Arc very soon and
that's because if Saint Saturn is
actually an extremely powerful ability
user s is clearly suggested here then we
could be headed for a surprising turn of
events for the straw hats because
remember that law and kids were both
soundly defeated in this very same Mark
so while we all easily expect Luffy to
come out on top here actually kind of
possible that Luffy could suffer a
similar defeat here I mean we've
discussed this in previous chapter
reviews but Egghead island has a ton of
striking parallels to the Sabbath ODI
archipelago art like most importantly
the crew is riding a super high wave of
confidence having just come from wano
and defeating an emperor of the sea so
knowing Oda this could be the perfect
time to snatch away all of our
expectations and deliver another
crushing blow just like when the straw
hats were separated at the end of
sabaori which they also entered with a
lot of confidence after Thriller bark
because if there is one thing that Luffy
always struggles with it is a new
surprising power that he just can punch
into the ground which does sound exactly
like what we could be getting from Sun
Saturn whenever he arrives at eckhit
Islands but taking us back let's swing
all the way back to EMU because there
are actually a few more mind-blowing
reveals that were shown in this chapter
so in the last chapter the godosai
actually named emu in front of King
Cobra and then here it appears that
Cobra is actually very familiar with the
name emu and Cobra himself basically
confirms that emu was the name of one of
the original 20 Kings but emu furiously
Cuts him off before he can say anything
else and so this seems to confirm a very
common theory that emu is actually from
the void century and while it is
possible that emu himself could just be
a descendant or reincarnation of the
original emu the information we get next
makes that very unlikely and that's
because emo then goes on to talk about
nifatadi Lily as if they had actually
known the former queen of alabaster
personally but we do not stop there
because the minds blowing reveals just
keep on coming I mean these recent
chapters this Arc in general has me
sweating every time I make one of these
reviews oh okay so next emu claims that
the D's were our enemies in the past
which I do assume means the 20 kingdoms
and even further they explain that
basically all of the world government's
problems today such as pirates trying to
find the pony glyphs and Scholars
researching the void Century all of that
can basically be traced back to a single
event that was all Lily's fault back
during the end of the Void Century okay
I mean this is literally incredible
finally we're starting to get answers
and more information about the void
century and it just feels amazing I mean
I hope you can relate to that now let's
take a moment to wrap our heads around
all of this because based on what emu
says here it seems there was some plot
to completely Wipe Out the ancient
Kingdom that was almost completely
successful however Lily spoiled the plan
somehow Maybe by failing in a certain
task or much more likely leaking some
secret information I mean they almost
make it sound like the creation of the
pony glyphs themselves go back to Lily
now why would she do this well maybe
because she was a d as well and actually
secretly allied with the ancient Kingdom
or maybe she was just friends with joy
boy but whatever the real reason her
action allowed for the opponent lives to
spread which gave hope to the Future
Generations as we are seeing in the
current storyline and Cobra even starts
to recite the secret letter that was
left behind by Lily which says to
protect the pony glyphs and to raise the
flag of dawn to the world so clearly
Lily for some reason decided to go
against the other 19 kingdoms and leave
a trail for future generations to follow
all of this clearly angers emu in this
chapter which then as we all knew was
gonna happen eventually leads to cobras
sacrificing himself so that Sabo can
escape and now what's even more
incredible is that this is not all that
we see in this epic turn of events
because just as important are the people
that emu wasn't able to kill in the
throne room and yes that is people
meaning plural more than one because
was able to escape because of
Cobra's sacrifice and his insanely
strong devil fruit now this guy was also
eavesdropping on the conversation and
when emu finally notices waffle here the
former ruler of drum Island who we all
really don't like at least so far
literally munches his way through the
walls of the castle and is somehow able
to actually Escape which hold on it's
actually very curious to me like does
that mean that emu let's wobble Escape
or maybe emo didn't want to make a
bigger scene then this already is
because clearly they have incredibly
Dangerous Powers and probably any of
them in that room could have chased down
warp hole somehow unless he got help
from someone else now regardless both
Walpole and Sabo have escaped with the
knowledge that the world government has
been hiding even more secrets than the
world has ever dreamed and at this point
there is absolutely no doubt in my mind
that the world will soon be learning
about Inu all though it is odd that the
world government has not been going
ballistic here trying to keep this info
quiet since it has already been over a
month remember since these events took
place so maybe they don't really care
that much which is actually even more
scary to think about anyways Sabo is
currently speaking with the leaders of
the Revolutionary Army and I cannot see
any other reason why they would keep
this a secret this knowledge is just
what they would need to bring more
countries and people to their side as
they try to overthrow the world Nobles
but even if for some big reason Dragon
decides to not reveal the secrets then
surely Walpole will Spill the Beans to
this big bird who is also head of the
newspaper that are delivered all over
the world worlds and we've already seen
that Morgan's refuses to let the world
government censor his news so unless he
ends up dead then he would have every
reason in the world to share the biggest
news that he has ever shared in the
story before and as we've just discussed
with the revolutionaries this would
surely change the world fundamentally I
mean the whole point of the empty Throne
is that the rulers of the world
government collectively rule the world
and I don't think all of these rulers
would be like super happy once they find
out that they've been actually been
secretly ruled by a Supreme Overlord
however none of that might really matter
since the strongest powers in the world
are basically already in play those are
of course the Marines the
revolutionaries the good Pirates like
the straw hats and the not quite so good
Pirates like Blackbeard so really what
does it even matter if these rulers
throw a fit because really they can't do
that much anyway as we just saw with
this Kingdom which was completely wiped
off the map no chance to defend
themselves at all now what is even more
insane though is that with the way
things are shaping up it is entirely
possible that all of these forces that I
just mentioned could actually team up to
take down emu and the celestial dragons
I mean just think about it more and more
and more emu is being set up here as the
final villain and with the Holy nights
of God just being introduced two
chapters ago there is a strong
possibility that emu and the gorosei and
the holy Knights will be the final
villains of the story with their own
super strong force including by the way
the seraphim and it will take the
combined efforts of Luffy Blackbeard and
the fleet Admiral Akainu to keep the
world from being cleansed it does seem
kind of out there admittedly but you
know Luffy the Sun but Blackbeard the
moon that's exactly what happened with
Naruto and Sasuke in that anime and also
Akino has often shown that he really
does not like the celestial dragons I
mean personally this twist would be
super interesting to me because it would
even subvert many of the expectations
that we've all had about the final
stages of one piece and you know what
else this final Alliance could all have
in common D because as we get closer to
the end of the story this mysterious
Initial D that has been around since the
very start of the story is starting to
seem like the final big clue and key
that will unveil every remaining secret
and once again we got even more
confirmation that the D's were the
original enemies of the 20 Kings and in
this chapter we learned that vivi's
family are actually part of bad d-tribe
as well so it's not just Pirates who
have this initial like Luffy Blackbeard
and even Roger nor is it just Marines or
revolutionaries like GARP and dragon no
this legendary clan of these also
included rulers of entire country so we
have to ask the question that naturally
arises from this reveal who exactly were
the D Clan what does it mean and who
else is secretly part of this family
because you can be sure that there's
people out there who we haven't known
about yet that they also have that
initial it's the D It's the
decree to these oh yeah that is the
secret to the D family wait what were
your opinions on this okay I agree now
before this chapter part of me had
wondered if the original 20 kingdoms
were all part of the days but that does
clearly not seem to be the case now it
does much more seem like the neftari
family were the only D's of the original
20 kingdoms since they were the only
ones to actually stay behind when the
other rulers went to marijuana and if
that is true then they must have had
some sort of alliance with the ancient
Kingdom as we've already discussed in
previous chapter reviews now whatever
the case we would be getting the answers
to these secrets very soon because
Cobra's last words to Sabo were for him
to tell Vivi and Luffy that his family
were all part of the days and we don't
actually know if Saba was able to talk
to Vivi after escaping I mean waffle
appears to have been listening and so he
could just have been able to pass
Cobra's message onto his daughter
already and since Vivi is yes very close
to echid Island apparently right now now
she could be meeting up with Luffy on
the scientific Island very soon but what
you may not realize here is that this
would also bring Vivi to the one person
who may actually have answers to all
those questions about the d-clan and of
course that would be Robin who has
already shown interest in the d-clan
three times in the past in chapter 180
she asked Luffy about his family
initials but he had no idea what they
meant and then in chapter 301 this old
Sky Knight spoke with the straw hats
about Luffy leaving the same impression
that Roger did when they visited the
islands the third time and the closest
she was to learning answers was in
shaki's bar on Saba ODI when the whole
crew listened intently as Rayleigh told
him about his journey with Roger to love
tail and Roger's former Vice Captain
basically implied that he knew the truth
of what the demand but Robin then
declined his offer to explain it all to
the straw hats right then and there but
all of this was before the time skip and
a lot has happened since then first she
spent two years with the revolutionaries
and in particular with dragon who is one
of the likeliest people in the entire
world to know about the truth about the
d-clan and on top of that she has read
many of the most important Pony glyphs
in the world during the recent arcs and
while we already knew that you may not
have ever realized that Robin actually
never shares what the pony glyphs
actually say I mean we assume that they
are about to void Century or about
directions to love tale but surely at
some point she will need to reveal the
actual words that are written on the
pony glyphs I mean this has to happen
right right and the perfect time for
this would of course be when the straw
hats then meet up with Vivi and the
alabaster princess then asks about her
Newfound family initial and while it
might seem ridiculous that Robin has
never shared any of this info with the
crew it's not really something that
Luffy cares about so he probably would
have never even asked her to begin with
but it is certainly something that we
care about so I can't wait for the
question to finally be answered soon
hopefully and even if Robin cannot
answer any of these questions there are
a few other characters who might easily
be able to help of course there is Dr
vegapunk Who has read the entire library
and research from the island of Ohara so
he's a good candidate as anyone to know
the truth or certainly it's even
possible that Saint Saturn could reveal
some answers during or after the
inevitable conflict on eckat island
another Dakota say might have finally
revealed their devil fruit Powers we
have to ask ourselves how high they will
end up ranking in all the devil fruits
in one piece and if you want to see the
top 5 most overpowered fruits in the
story right now in my opinion well you
can watch that video right here thanks
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one